let me ask you on that topic
uh elon musk tesla autopilot
one of the only companies i believe is
really pushing for a learning based
approach
are you you're skeptical that that kind
of network can achieve level four
l4 uh is probably achievable
l5 probably not what's the distinction
there
as l5 is completely you can just fall
asleep
yeah alpha is basically human level well
it will drive you have to be careful
saying human level because like
that's yeah they're almost drivers yeah
that's the clearest example of like
you know cars will most likely be much
safer than humans in situ
in many situations where humans fail
it's the
vice versa so i'll tell you you know
the thing is the amounts of training
data you would need
to anticipate for pretty much every
possible situation
you learn content in the real world is
such that
it's not entirely unrealistic to think
that at some point in the future we'll
develop a system that's running on
enough data especially uh
provided that we can assimilate a lot of
that data
we don't necessarily need actual uh
actual calls on the road
uh for everything uh but it's a massive
effort and it turns out you can create a
system that's
much more adaptative uh that can
generalize much better
if you just add
explicit models of the surroundings of
the car
and if you use deep learning for what
it's good at which is to provide
perceptive information so in general
deep learning is is
a a way to encode perception and a way
to encode intuition
but it is not a good medium for any sort
of
explicit reasoning and
uh in ai systems today strong
generalization tends to
come from um explicit
models tend to come from abstractions in
the human mind that are encoded
in program form by a human engineer
right yeah these are the abstractions it
can actually generalize not the sort of
weak abstraction that is learned by a
neural network yeah and the question is
how much
uh how much reasoning how much strong
abstractions are required to solve
particular tasks like driving that's
that's the question or human life
existence how much
how much strong obs abstractions does
existence
require but more specifically on driving
that's that seems to be that seems to be
a coupled
question about intelligence is like uh
how much
intelligence like how do you build an
intelligent system
and uh the coupled problem how hard is
this problem
how much intelligence does this problem
actually require
so we're um we get to cheat right
because we get to look at the problem
like it's not like you get to close
our eyes and completely new to driving
we get to do what we do as
human beings which is uh for the
majority of our life
before we ever learn quote unquote to
drive we get to watch other
cars and other people drive we get to be
in cars we get to
watch we get to get and see movies about
cars we get to
you know we have to observe all this
stuff and that's similar to what neural
networks are doing
it's getting a lot of data and
the the the question is yeah how much
is uh how many leaps of reasoning genius
is required
to be able to actually effectively drive
oh it's for example of driving
i mean sure um you've seen a lot of cars
in your life before you learn to drive
but let's say you've learned to drive in
silicon valley
and now you rent a car in tokyo
well now everyone is driving on the
other side of the road and the signs are
different
and the roads are more narrow and so on
so it's a very very different
environment
and uh a smart human even an average
human
should be able to just zero shot it to
just
be operational in this in this very
different environment
yeah right away despite having add
new contact with the novel complexity
that is contained in this environment
right and that is another complexity is
not just
interpolation over the situations that
you've encountered previously
like learning to drive in the u.s right
i would say
the reason i ask this one of the most
interesting tests of intelligence we
have today
actively which is driving
in terms of having an impact on the
world like when do you think we'll pass
that test of intelligence
so i i don't think driving is that much
of a test intelligence because again
there is no task for which skid at that
task
demonstrates intelligence unless uh it's
a kind of meta task that involves
acquiring uh new skills so i don't think
i think you can actually solve driving
without having
any any real amount of intelligence for
instance if you really did have infinite
trained data
um you could just literally train an
end-to-end deep learning model that's
driving
provided infinite training data the only
problem
with the whole idea is
collecting a data sets that's
sufficiently comprehensive that covers
the very long tail of possible
situations you might encounter
and it's really just a scale problem so
i think the
there's nothing fundamentally wrong
uh uh with this plan with this idea it's
just that
um it strikes me as a fairly inefficient
thing to do because you run
into this this uh scanning issue with
diminishing returns whereas
if instead you took a more manual
engineering approach
where you use deep learning
modules in combination
with engineering an explicit model
of the surrounding of the cause and you
and you bridge the two in a clever way
your model will actually start
generalizing much earlier
and more effectively than the end-to-end
deep learning model so why would you not
go with the more manual
engineering-oriented approach
like even if you created that system
either the end-to-end deep learning
model system industry on infinite data
or
the slightly more human system
i i don't think achieving l5 would
demonstrate
a general intelligence or intelligence
of any generality at all again the only
possible test
of generality in ai would be a test that
looks at skill acquisition over unknown
tasks
but for instance you could take your l5
driver and ask it to
to learn to to pilot a commercial
airplane for instance
and then you would look at how much
human involvement is required and how
much training data is required
uh for the system to learn to pilot an
airplane and uh
that that gives you a measure of how
intelligent that system
is yeah well i mean that's a big leap i
get you but
i'm more interested as a problem i would
see to me driving is
a black box that can generate novel
situations
at some rate that what people call edge
cases
like so it does have newness that keeps
being
like we're confronted let's say once a
month
it is a very long time yes long term
that doesn't mean you cannot solve it
uh just by by training a statistical
model a lot of data
huge amount of data it's it's really a
matter of scale
but i guess what i'm saying is if you
have a
vehicle that achieves level five it is
going to be
able to deal with new situations
or i mean the data is so large
that the rate of new situations is
very low yes that's not intelligent so
uh if we go back to your kind of
definition of intelligence it's the
efficiency
with which you can adapt to new
situations to truly new situations not
situations you've seen before
right right not situations that could be
anticipated by your creators by the
creators of the system
but three new situations the efficiency
with which you
acquire new skills if you require if in
order to pick up a new skill you require
um a very extensive
training data set of most possible
situations that can that can occur
in the practice of that skill then the
system is not intelligent it is mostly
just
a lookup table yeah
well likewise if uh in order to acquire
a skill you need
a human engineer to write down a bunch
of rules that cover
most or every possible situation
likewise the system is is not
intentioned the system is merely
the output artifact uh of a process that
that depends that happens in the minds
of of the engineers that are creating it
right it is including
uh an abstraction that's produced by the
human mind
and intelligence that would actually be
the process of producing of autonomously
producing this abstraction
yeah not like if you take an abstraction
and you encode it
on a piece of paper or in a computer
program the abstraction itself
is not intelligent what's intelligent is
the the agent that's capable of
producing these abstractions
right yeah it feels like there's a
little bit of a gray area
like because you're basically saying
that deep learning forms abstractions
too but those abstractions
do not seem to be effective for
generalizing far
outside of the things it's already seen
but generalize a little bit
yeah absolutely no deep learning does
generalize a little bit like
generalization is not it's not a binary
it's mark a spectrum
yeah and there's a certain point it's a
gray area but there's a certain point
where there's an impressive degree of
generalization
that happens no like
i guess exactly what you were saying is
uh intelligence is um
how efficiently you're able to
generalize
far outside of the distribution of
things you've seen already
yes so it's both like the the distance
of how far you can
like how new how radically new something
is
and how efficiently yes absolutely so
you you can think of
uh intelligence as a measure of an
information conversion ratio
like imagine a space of possible
situations
and you've covered some of them
so you have some amount of information
about your space of possible situations
that's provided by the situations you
already know
and that's on the other hand also
provided by
the prior knowledge that the system
brings to the table the prior knowledge
that's embedded
in the system so the system starts with
some information
right about the problem about the task
and
it's about going from that information
to
a program what you would call a skill
program a behavioral program
that can cover a large area of possible
situation space
and essentially the ratio between that
area and the amount of information you
start with
is intelligence
so a very smart agent uh can make
efficient uses
of very little information about a new
problem and very little prior knowledge
as well
to cover a very large area of potential
situations in that problem
without knowing what these future new
situations are going to be
you